[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au menu de
l'actualité et des idées de sortie des
infos pratiques une édition spéciale
enregistrée ici au pyramides du Port
Marly à l'occasion des universités des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien voici le
programme de CE2 octobre
l'édition 2022 de l'uemoop s'est
déroulée toute la journée au pyramides
du port marlyre rendez-vous phare des
mers des Yvelines et des Hauts-de-Seine
pour se rencontrer échanger avec leur
partenaire et parler de leurs
problématiques actuelles 24 conférences
thématiques des tables rondes et des
formations étaient au programme sur
place près de 2000 participants c'est
parti pour 5 jours de compétition les
Championnats du monde de cyclisme
surpissent se tiennent jusqu'à dimanche
au Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines la cérémonie d'ouverture se
tient à 18h et la France a des chances
de médailles dès ce soir et nous sont
sur place dans un instant et puis
direction Saint-Germain-en-Laye avec
cette exposition qui a démarré au Musée
départemental Maurice Denis femmes et
visible jusqu'au 2 juillet prochain elle
met en lumière des artistes féminines
peu connus avec des
dépôt et c'est pas le seul qui a ce
phénomène dans sa commune et donc ce
sera tout à l'heure dans un instant
également Patrice Carmaux directeur de
l'information tv70
avec vous on va parler logement
urbanisme et le sujet de la rénovation
urbaine du côté de la commune de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes c'est d'ailleurs
notre invité il y a notre invité qui est
sur ce plateau avec les Catherine Arnaud
la mère de Chanteloup-les-Vignes puisque
hier pour sa première visite en France
là la présidente de Landru qui est
Catherine Vautrin et bien tu allais en
Yvelines notamment à son tour des vignes
et on va en parler tout à l'heure avec
avec Catherine Arnaud peut-être une
première question Catherine Arnaud sur
ces universités des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien pourquoi vous en tant que mère
c'était intéressant important de venir
d'être présente sur sur cet événement
aujourd'hui d'abord c'est une habitude
qui est bien agréable alors c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer d'abord de
rencontrer les maires d'autres communes
pour partager mais c'est aussi parce
qu'on a des on a des des thématiques qui
nous sont communes avec des experts et
on peut échanger on peut venir chercher
des idées nouvelles on peut partager des
idées et puis on peut aussi recevoir un
prix c'est ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
et oui le prix de l'innovation pour la
cité éducative Simone Veil qui va qui
sera que vous apporte quand ah ben on
l'espère septembre 2025 2025 on en dit
un peu plus tout à l'heure dans cette
émission mais tout de suite c'est
l'heure des informations du jour
peut-être
et à côté de ces universités des mairies
à l'actualité et danse ce mercredi dans
les Yvelines tension autour du carburant
visite de la première dame à Poissy et
des championnats du monde qui débutent
dans le département on fait le point
avec Céline Charles l'ambiance est
toujours tendue aux portes des stations
services le mouvement de grève qui
touche les raffineries de carburant en
France s'étend et s'intensifie malgré
l'annonce de réquisition des personnels
de la raffinerie Esso exon mobile par le
gouvernement hier soir 30% des stations
sont en pénurie selon le ministère de la
transition écologique
Brigitte Macron président de la
Fondation des hôpitaux s'est rendu cet
après-midi à la Maison les trois arches
à Poissy centre d'accompagnement des
personnes atteintes de cancer de leurs
proches la première dame de France y a
rencontré des intervenants et
bénéficiaires dans le cadre du Mois de
sensibilisation au cancer du sein
octobre rose top départ pour le
championnat du monde de cyclisme sur
piste au Vélodrome de 50 ans en Yvelines
il se dérouleront jusqu'au dimanche 16
octobre et regrouperont les meilleurs
pistards internationaux la cérémonie
d'ouverture se déroule à 18h des
médailles françaises sont possibles dès
le premier jour le Football Club de
Versailles sur le terrain ce soir les
Yvelines noires reçoivent le Mans pour
la 9e journée de Nationale coup d'envoi
à 19h30 au stade Jean-Bouin Versailles
8e Le Mans 10e au classement le FC
Versailles qui enregistré cette semaine
l'arrivée d'un ancien joueur
professionnel passé par Le Mans
l'international togolais Mathieu
dossevis s'est engagé avec le club de la
cité royale il portera le numéro 14 elle
se déroule cette année du 10 au 16
octobre la Semaine du Goût fait la
promotion de la culture le patrimoine
culinaire et le Bien manger au plus
grand nombre visite de ferme dégustation
de produits du terroir de nombreux
activités sont proposées dans les
Yvelines la ferme de galliès
Saint-Cyr-l'École organise sa fête du
goût le dimanche 16 octobre
et donc toujours depuis ces universités
des mairies de l'Ouest parisien qui se
tenait ce mercredi ici au pyramides et
du Port Marly et on va parler avec notre
invité Patrice de rénovation urbaine
puisque Catherine Vautrin qui est la
présidente de la rue c'est l'Agence
nationale de la rénovation urbaine est
venu justement hier c'était le 11
octobre dans les Yvelines dans deux
communes chantent les vignes et les
Mureaux et Les Mureaux commune on
pourrait dire qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
couleurs politiques mais au fond les
problèmes sur les mêmes sont les mêmes
c'est des communes de cette grande
vallée de la Seine qui ont eu les
constructions très importantes pour
accueillir les populations entre autres
de l'industrie automobile et c'est
Poissy Chanteloup Les Mureaux
Mantes-la-Jolie voilà c'est c'est en
fait les mêmes populations ça a été les
mêmes histoires c'est les mêmes
populations c'est la même volonté de de
faire évoluer nos villes de normaliser
nos villes de redonner du cadre de vie
de la qualité de vie à nos habitants et
de refaire de la mixité aussi parce que
notre but notre but ça n'est pas que de
faire de l'urbain notre but est
d'accompagner avec tout un tas de
processus et dispositifs originaux le
plus originaux possible les habitants
entre autres les enfants parce que c'est
aussi les habitants de notre territoire
à être des vrais citoyens et à réussir
avec leurs propres compétences faire de
l'urbain c'est aussi refaire de la ville
sur la ville et puis c'est aussi donner
au à toute habitant donc il soit la
capacité d'avoir un parcours résidentiel
ça c'est très important il faut pas que
les gens soient enfermés dans un lieu il
faut qu'on leur donne les occasions de
choisir là où ils veulent vivre et
peut-être la fierté aussi d'habiter
dans cette ville et ça vous l'avez donné
beaucoup gagné la fierté mais mais
souvent l'accompagner parce que il y a
beaucoup de parents qui sont fiers de
leurs enfants et les enfants qui sont
fiers de leurs parents nous on a nous on
a besoin de faire marcher cette cette
mayonn pour montrer que cette fierté
elle est elle est juste elle est juste
et elle est partagée alors on va
peut-être revenir sur le sur la visite
de Catherine Vautrin tout à fait alors
Catherine Vautrin est venu donc mardi
de Chanteloup-les-Vignes et Julien Leroy
était sur place alors je vous propose
d'abord un premier extrait ou Catherine
Vautrin explique quelles sont les
objectifs de la rue l'objectif c'est de
rassembler toutes celles et ceux qui
peuvent participer au logement dans les
quartiers avec donc bien sûr les
bailleurs sociaux mais également Action
Logement qui a pour vocation de cotiser
pour faciliter le logement des salariés
l'état bien évidemment les communes les
collectivités la Caisse des dépôts et
donc tout cet ensemble de gens a pour
objectif de présenter et d'accompagner
des projets qui permettent de
restructurer nos quartiers
c'est une démission importante de la rue
c'est justement la rénovation des
quartiers des logements
comment ça dans cette vidéo c'est pas
qu'il aurait qui est l'enrui
c'est une agence une agence qui existe
qui a été créé par Jean-Louis Borloo
bien évidemment l'idée était vraiment au
départ de mettre une espèce de force de
frappe énorme qui était l'état
Action Logement dans c'est une démission
un de créer du logement les
collectivités locales
et puis évidemment les différents
ministères et l'idée était que à un
moment donné on souhaite tous en
capacité de mettre des moyens
considérables alors que ça avait été
perfusé par petit bout depuis des années
qu'on n'avait pas la possibilité de de
faire un changement profond de mon
territoire le premier le premier sujet
c'était le sujet du logement alors rue a
d'abord été créé pour ça parce qu'il
était financé par Action Logement et il
est toujours essentiellement financé par
excisionnement c'était de refaire du
logement puisque les logements étaient à
la vraie problématique la qualité de vie
des habitants était la vraie
problématique mais on s'est aperçu que
on ne pouvait pas faire que du logement
on ne vivait pas que dans son logement
on vit de l'espace public on vit des
équipements on vit des services publics
et tout ça c'était autant de choses qui
n'existaient plus dans nos territoires
donc la rue c'est à la fois accompagné
l'aménagement de l'espace public
l'aménagement des logements la
construction
construction reconstruction
réhabilitation des logements mais aussi
fournir permettent aux collectivités
locales de créer des équipes publics de
qualité et porter quelquefois quelques
idées un peu un peu novatrices pour
voilà pour pour accompagner nos
habitants mais pour quelques fois faire
tâches d'huile et puis que ça servent
aussi à l'ensemble de la population les
idées novatrices notamment à Chanteloup
heavy il y a ces projets des cités
Champeaux cité Simone Weiss si vous
pouvez en dire un mot pour les présenter
alors l'ensemble de notre projet de
renouvellement urbains sont tous les
vignes et il est effectivement la cité
éducative c'est quoi la cité éducative
c'est l'endroit où l'ensemble des
acteurs qui accompagnent l'enfant dans
son évolution peuvent porter le projet
ensemble ça veut dire quoi en gros c'est
ici nous sommes tous acteurs de
l'éducation vous les enseignants vous
les animateurs du périscolaire vous les
associations qui accompagnaient l'enfant
hors temps scolaire mais surtout vous
les parents qui êtes le premier
éducateur et vous les enfants parce que
vous avez selon votre âge des choses à
dire et comment on peut et nous on
travaille depuis le début 2019 sur un on
est accompagné on travaille sur un
projet pour que les acteurs travaillent
ensemble chez nous ces acteurs que je
viens de vous citer ils ont travaillé
ensemble pour dire quelle était la
lecture de l'école de demain selon eux
l'école complètement mutualisée où on
partageait tout on partageait tous les
projets notre lecture donc leur lecture
s'est transformé en en un cahier des
charges qu'on a remis aux architectes
pour faire un concours d'architecte et
maintenant l'archite les architectes qui
ont été retenus sont en train de créer
l'objet dans lequel c'est l'ensemble de
ces acteurs vont fabriquer leurs projets
et comment en fait ça se fait avec des
constructions reconstruction de cette
idée éducative qu'on pourrait comparer à
un campus et en gros c'est la maternelle
l'élémentaire le collège le périscolaire
la bibliothèque médiathèque La Maison
des Parents et comme en fait ça se
construit sur un endroit où on démolit
des il y avait ce temps intermédiaire
qu'il fallait qu'il fallait utiliser et
ce temps intermédiaire on a décidé de
nous de construire ce qu'on appelle la
cité Champeaux c'est un c'est un lieu
unique construit en moins de 10 mois
avec des conceptions extrêmement
nouvelles dans le dans l'architecture
qui est vraiment l'incubateur et
actuellement dans cette cité champion
qu'on a ouvert au début de l'année il y
a tous les enfants de cette école qui
vont après retrouver ce grand campus qui
vivent ensemble avec l'ensemble de leurs
éducateurs ce c'est vraiment cette
incubateur du grand projet cité
éducative pour dire que c'est
l'excellence dans le quartier si vous
voulez l'excellence dans les quartiers
c'est aussi c'est aussi quelque chose
qui est très important c'est qu'en fait
tout ça c'est au tour de l'enfant et de
sa réussite et qu'on ne compare du
principe que chaque enfant a une
compétence
bien de commencer et ce sont plusieurs
milliards d'euros qui ont été mis en
avant pour reconstruire les quartiers et
donc ce qui est très intéressant ici à
Chanteloup c'est de voir déjà ce qui
s'est fait dans la commune sur ce
premier projet de rénovation urbaine des
percées de rue des démolitions des
reconstitutions
un peu sa conviction qu'il faut agir
partout en même temps c'est ça c'est
partout en même temps tous ensemble sur
tous les sujets ce qui n'existait pas
n'hésitez pas effectivement c'est la
capacité c'est la capacité de tout faire
en même temps pour pour que le
renouvellement soit massif et que les
habitants soient partis prenant de ce
renouvellement c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
bien compris le département parce que
vous savez que la politique du
département dans les Yvelines est
exceptionnelle elle n'existe dans aucun
autre département de France puisque
l'investissement du département dans ces
quartiers c'est surtout les sujets en
même temps mais essentiellement aussi
sur le sujet éducatif parce que le
département il y a vu une vraie un vrai
investissement donc il festif sur ses
collèges mais il investit sur tous les
autres temps scolaires et
l'investissement du département dans les
Yvelines c'est un peu plus deux fois
l'investissement de la rue c'est
peut-être pas au hasard d'ailleurs si la
première visite de Catherine Vautrin
nouvelle présidente a été dans les
Yvelines je pense indépendamment du fait
que voilà c'est aussi Chanteloup c'est
aussi un bébé Borlo et que Catherine
Vautrin a travaillé avec Jean-Louis et
avec vous il y a aussi une idée que vous
portez c'est celle de la mixité dans
dans ce quartier pour la rénovation
urbaine c'est quelque chose que vous
prenez aussi ah oui alors la mixité
c'est pas quelque chose qui s'invente ni
qui s'impose la mixité doit se faire
naturellement mais la mixité c'est c'est
quelque chose quand vous dites je fais
du parcours résidentiel pour les
habitants du logement social qui ont
envie de devenir propriétaire à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes et que vous y
réussissez vous faites de la mixité
c'est à dire que vous la mixité c'est
aussi l'équilibre entre le locataire le
propriétaire entre celui qui s'investit
longtemps dans le territoire
celui qui s'investit qui ne fait que
passer et puis c'est sorti c'est surtout
sortir de ce tout logement social
puisque vous savez les quartiers de
notre de notre vallée de la Seine était
100% de logements social Nicolas c'est
intéressant aussi dans le projet de la
cité éducative et on l'a pu le voir dans
plusieurs reportages sur TV 78 c'est que
c'est un projet qui est porté à la fois
par la commune par les associations le
tissu associatif de la commune mais
aussi le ministère de l'éducation à
travers la principale qui est qui porte
le projet et la sous-préfete aussi on
voit que l'ensemble finalement ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne le schéma
administratif de français fonctionne
entre les différents échelons alors là
aussi le label cité éducatif qui existe
nous avons été expérimentateur il y a eu
80 cités éducatives expérimentales qui
ont commencé en 2019 on a été un des
premiers expérimentateurs c'est
effectivement porté par un trépied c'est
une directrice de projet ville une
principale de collège éducation
nationale et la délégué du préfet est à
pourquoi parce que on ne peut plus faire
de l'éducation tout seul c'est une façon
de montrer qu'on ne peut plus te faire
d'éducation tout seul et qu'on porte
l'ensemble du projet cette éducatif avec
ce trépied là et je dois dire que dans
les Yvelines on est terriblement bien
accompagné par l'Éducation nationale par
la directrice départementale de
l'Éducation nationale et par lactrice
qui est très attentive à ses projets
éducatifs j'en reviens juste sur le
sujet de la mixité puisque Julien Leroy
qui était hier à Chanteloup-les-Vignes à
poser justement la question sur le sujet
aussi à Catherine votre a écouté ce que
l'on constate c'est qu'on est arrivé une
vraie mixité sociale il y avait hier à
Chanteloup quand je dis hier c'est 2004
il y avait 86% de logements sociaux
aujourd'hui il y a encore 56% de
logements sociaux mais il y a d'autres
personnes qui sont venues habiter
Chanteloup qui pour certaines ont accédé
à la propriété donc ont acheté et on est
dans ce qu'on trouve dans toutes les
villes de France c'est-à-dire une mixité
d'habitants
oui
le chiffre de 56% actuellement 46%
maintenant quand vous êtes arrivés
c'était combien alors moi je suis arrivé
il y avait 75% de les réseaux sociaux
donc c'est un défaut absolument
considérable et on n'est pas on n'est
pas du tout le monde imagine qu'on est
dans la démolition intense c'est pour ça
qu'on baisse pas du tout la démolition
démolition il faut surtout qu'on a fait
des projets d'accession à la propriété
accessible on a on a décidé de quelle
allait notre peuplement c'est-à-dire
nous on le principe c'est d'accueillir
des jeunes couples avec un enfant qui
vont s'installer de venir primo-occident
et qui vont s'installer durablement dans
le territoire et c'est et puis changer
l'image vous savez l'image des quartiers
c'est un peu compliqué et pour attirer
des nouvelles populations faut des
fautes des produits d'excellence comme
la cité éducative mais il faut aussi
changer l'image j'ai eu la chance de
faire une émission en immersion un peu à
Chanteloup et c'est vrai que j'ai
discuté avec des jeunes gens qui sont
qui sont nés là et zéro une fierté de
cette ville d'aujourd'hui et ça c'est
vrai que ça change tout quoi l'image
même vis-à-vis des gens qui habitent
c'est très important faut être fier d'où
on vient il faut être fier où on va un
tout dernier mot peut-être sur le
calendrier 2027 c'est la fin de la
rénovation urbaine normalement elle
chante tous les vignes c'est la data
annoncée alors je pense que j'espère que
2025 26 parce que en dehors des
équipements publics vous avez bien
compris qu'il y a aussi tout un
aménagement des constructions
construction pour faire de l'accession
sociale à la propriété de l'accession et
donc ça c'est des projets qui vont se
faire au fil du temps pour accueillir
des populations nouvelles merci beaucoup
Catherine Arnaud un petit dernier mot
tout dernier mois
un type dernier mot sur le ruban rose
que Catherine Arnaud a son à sa veste
c'est octobre rose la prévention contre
le cancer du sein et un sujet très
important et ça j'en profite pour saluer
plus personnellement une personne très
proche par rapport à ce sujet là voilà
le message est passé Nicolas merci
Catherine Arnaud d'être venu avec nous
sur ce plateau je rappelle le maire de
la commune de Chanteloup-les-Vignes
concerné par le décrétaire Sierre j'en
ai un là que je vais refaire c'est le
gymnase Pierre de Coubertin un gymnase
c'est 9 millions d'euros minimum de
travaux 40 bâtiments à refaire si je le
fais tout seul avec les diminutions de
notation de l'État et bien je n'y
arriverai pas les conséquences de cette
inflation sur le budget des classes sous
bois par exemple c'est à peu près 1,5
millions d'euros à trouver pour l'an
prochain 1,5 millions d'euros c'est à
minima 15% d'augmentation des impôts le
sujet de l'automobile financière dont on
a entendu parler l'autonomie financière
des collectivités mais les élus
demandent aussi la mise en place d'un
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie un
accompagnement financé sur les travaux
d'isolation thermique des équipements
publics demandés par l'État ah bah moi
sur la commune de Villepreux j'ai de
fortes interrogations sur le théâtre et
la piscine je sais pas si je serai en
mesure de l'ouvrir un corps cette été
parce que c'est des charges de personnel
c'est je cherche de fonctionnement il y
a toujours des petits travaux à faire et
puis sur notre théâtre aujourd'hui moi
je vais demander un moratoire sur le
théâtre parce que aujourd'hui je vais
être obligé de faire des travaux
d'accessibilité du bâtiment et j'ai pas
les moyens sur le budget que j'ai
actuellement pour le faire ah bah là on
se sent incompris
et abandonner il y a 9 associations bien
sûr d'élus qui sont en train de se
mobiliser dont la MF donc de toute façon
ce n'est qu'à mon avis le début d'un
rassemblement bien sûr assez vaste je
pense des élus français alors là on le
voit il y a des élus qui veulent même
diminuer les services municipaux on
l'entendait tout à l'heure dans la table
ronde sur et bien sur le coup de
l'énergie
Jean-Baptiste amonique qu'on a entendu
dans l'interview parlé d'un blackout
territorial peut-être la fermeture de
certains services municipaux et à noter
aussi que le 27 septembre dernier une
délégation d'élus emmenée par
Jean-Michel fourgousse le président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
qu'on vient d'entendre et bien a été
reçu à Bercy au ministère de l'Économie
pour évoquer avec Gabriel Attal et ben
ces difficultés là voilà ouais Patrice
vous avez eu l'occasion d'interviewer de
nombreux maires des élus locaux aussi
c'est la crainte principale aujourd'hui
c'est l'inflation c'est le sujet qui
revient souvent sur la table c'est le
financement c'est ils disent voilà on a
une baisse de recettes et et des
dépenses qui augmentent donc comment on
fait on n'est pas sûr dotation de l'État
de moins en moins forte donc on sait pas
on sait pas comment faire il y a une
véritable angoisse c'est vrai qu'on soit
une véritable angoisse c'est les mères
qui étaient réunis ici mais c'est vrai
que c'est l'un des sujets que qu'on a pu
sur lequel on a pu échanger avec eux au
cours de ces universités des mairies on
va changer un peu de sujet on va parler
de sport vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'il y a un gros événement qui a
démarré aujourd'hui le Drôme peut-être
au Vélodrome peut-être Nicolas Grégory
vous allez monter sur le vélo ou pas non
malheureusement c'est pas moi qui vais
monter sur le vélo heureusement pour la
France heureusement aussi en Italie à
l'Italie que j'affectionne tout
particulièrement parce que tout de suite
on va parler sport dans dans cette
émission
le 7 8 enregistré ici au pyramides du
Port-Marly à l'occasion et des
universités des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien alors on vous a fait un petit
teasing aujourd'hui c'est l'autre
actualité fort du jour c'est le début de
ces Championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste c'est jusqu'à dimanche au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
alors au programme aujourd'hui il y a la
cérémonie d'ouverture il y a aussi les
toutes premières épreuves avec notamment
des chances de médailles françaises et
on retrouve sur place notre journaliste
sport Michaël et minero il est
accompagné de notre consultant cyclisme
sur TV 78 c'est Yann du Jarrier oui
Grégory les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur pistes sont débutés
aujourd'hui au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à mes côtés
notre consultant à Yann dujari alors
Yann est-ce que ça sera grandiose ces
championnats du monde ici au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
bien sûr que ça va être grandiose
l'organisation est vraiment parfaite
pour le moment et puis je j'ai l'intime
conviction que les résultats vont être
encore meilleur qu'il y a qu'il y a 8 7
ans maintenant meilleur qu'en 2015 tout
simplement et donc l'ambiance qui va
être générée par ce vélo Drôme et par
tous les spectateurs va être énorme et
on a déjà eu un aperçu tout à l'heure
sur la calife des sur les qualifications
des filles en vitesse par équipe et
comme vous le disiez au niveau des
résultats c'était extraordinaire on peut
le dire quasiment en 2015 avec 5
médailles d'or pour l'équipe de France
et deux de bronze est-ce que cette année
vous l'avez plus ou moins dit avant
est-ce qu'ils vont faire mieux cette
équipe de France j'ai au fond de moi
j'ai l'impression que cette équipe de
France est meilleur et la meilleure que
l'on ait pu avoir depuis de nombreuses
années et j'en ai déjà discuté et c'est
un peu le ressenti le ressenti général
ils n'ont pas voulu afficher de
d'objectif de de médaille mais je pense
que oui ils vont faire mieux parce que
généralement on s'appuie sur quelques
athlètes pour avoir les pour avoir et
donc si c'est pour avoir des résultats
et si ces athlètes avaient une
contreperformance bah ça ça gâchait le
résultat là on peut vraiment briller sur
plein de
à plein d'endroits et on peut voir de
très belles surprises il y a une
cinquantaine de nations présentes ici
sur ce vélo de route nationale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est bien
c'est bien la fête en fait du cyclisme
sur piste du cyclisme sur piste oui et
d'ailleurs il y a de plus en plus de
nations il y a des petites nations là on
a vu le Nigéria qui a été éliminé mais
on a des des participants du Laos on a
des petites nations qui qui n'étaient
pas présentes en 2015 donc oui la piste
devient un une discipline de sportive à
part entière dans le cycload dans dans
le cyclisme il y aura une cérémonie
d'ouverture dans quelques instants au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
ça sera à 18h cette cérémonie
d'ouverture qu'est-ce que ça représente
c'est quelque chose un moment important
c'est non c'est l'inauguration tout
simplement c'est la c'est le départ donc
là aujourd'hui un petit peu comme Roland
Garros vous avez le premier match bon
bah là on a les qualifications en ce
moment et après on fait la cérémonie et
c'est parti et après la cérémonie on
aura la vitesse par équipe et là il va y
avoir du très très gros spectacle et je
pense que
renforcer seront
seront à l'heure pour briller on le voit
derrière nous les tribunes ne sont pas
encore remplies c'est le début de ces
championnats du monde est-ce que ça va
monter en puissance aussi au fur et à
mesure des jours je crois qu'on annonce
complet non complet il y a plus de place
pour samedi et dimanche il y a encore de
la possibilité de venir pour vendredi
soir et jeudi et encore aujourd'hui
venez voir parce que sur une piste le
spectacle et là et l'ambiance est
complètement différente d'une course de
vélo traditionnelle donc venez voir vous
allez voir et et et vous vivrez avec
nous et vous vibrerez avec nous pendant
le pendant les pendant les épreuves un
rendez-vous peut-être s'il y a du
Jarrier à noter dans son agenda sur ces
championnats du monde alors rendez-vous
à ne pas manquer
le Karine demain Karine homme demain je
pense que ça va être une grosse grosse
bagarre ce soir la vitesse par équipe
homme et vitesse maritime femme moi j'ai
j'y crois mais je dirais que tous les
jours il y a des très belles finales il
va y avoir des beaux matchs tous les
jours quel que soit les quelques soient
lisbines on va voir un Philippe ogana en
vue en poursuite individuel avec enfin
voilà il y a tenteur du record de
l'heure voilà de la semaine dernière
avec son avec son vélo à 60 000 euros il
va y avoir une amie une paire en
américaine dimanche qui va être une
paire française qui va être énorme et
Donovan Grondin voilà c'est c'est des
c'est des des coureurs qui dominent et
qui sont complètement pas dire qu'il
domine mais qui sont présents à toutes
les compétitions internationales et qui
ont des résultats depuis depuis
plusieurs plusieurs mois et plusieurs
années donc je pense que là avec
l'immunération du public ça va être
grandiose c'est un petit peu la
tradition chez tv78 il faut se mouiller
donner un pronostic sur ces championnats
du monde je vais bien sûr pas vous
demander les pronostics pour chaque
nation mais ça qui nous intéresse c'est
forcément la France
un pronostic il y a une Jarrier grand
nombre de médailles d'or
allez moi je vais partir sur 6 plus
qu'en 2015 une de plus qu'en 2015 et je
pense que ce sera ce serait vraiment un
minimum merci à Yann Jarrier consultant
pour tb78 sur C championnat du monde de
cyclisme sur piste des championnats du
monde qui se dérouleront jusqu'à ce
dimanche 16 octobre ici sur ce
magnifique vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
bon Patrice Nicolas on va être tous
derrière la France bon moi j'ai une
petite aussi préférence pour l'Italie
mais on va la mettre de côté mais on va
être derrière la France on croit des
chances de médaille il y avait eu 5
médailles en or lors des derniers
championnats du monde en 2015 au
Vélodrome
de savoir si on fera la même chose qu'en
il croit vraiment en début de semaine il
était dans le 7 8 de lundi il disait
qu'on allait peut-être faire mieux que
justement cette performance là vous y
croyez on peut en faire mieux on verra
on verra en tout cas vous allez le voir
le directeur du programme olympique
c'est Florian Rousseau qui a un ex grand
voir aussi bleu l'une se prononce pas il
s'est moins mouillé sur la question
quand on lui a posé la question
forcément de l'objectif des médailles
pour les bleus sur ces championnats du
monde d'autant qu'en plus les Bleus on
le disait on brillait aux championnats
du monde en 2015 on brillé lors des
derniers championnats d'Europe c'était à
Munich l'été dernier on écoute tout de
suite Florian Rousseau je vous le disais
directement du programme olympique à la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme
[Applaudissements]
elle va bien elle vit bien beaucoup
d'ambition on a une équipe compétitive
tous les athlètes sélectionnés sont
montés sur des internationaux au cours
de cette année 2022 voilà donc on est
capable avec nos athlètes de jouer les
premiers rôles et il y a beaucoup
d'envies et forcément quand on est
athlète et compétiteur en équipe de
France on prend le départ pour la gagne
[Musique]
les objectifs je me les suis fixé avec
les staffs pas que de mon côté avec avec
les entraîneurs mais le bilan
quantitatif et qualitatif on le fera à
l'issue de ce championnat du monde
[Musique]
une bonne préparation je dirais qu'une
plutôt qu'une répétition oui certains
vont découvrir un championnat du monde à
domicile avec beaucoup de concurrence
forcément une intensité beaucoup
d'engagement dans les compétitions avec
les adversaires Olivier que les
adversaires viennent ici aussi à
Saint-Quentin dans la perspective des
Jeux de prendre de l'information donc
les cours seront très engagés très
denses et oui c'est une bonne
préparation pour monter en puissance à
moins de deux ans des jeux
[Applaudissements]
il le rappelait Florian Rousseau il y a
quand même une échéance qui arrive et
grandeur nature c'est ces Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 et le vélo va
accueillir justement les épreuves alors
il le dit il y a des athlètes qui
viennent là un peu aussi en repérage
c'est quand même des championnats du
monde mais il y a notamment les Anglais
par exemple les Anglais viennent surtout
pour repérer et pour être très très fort
aux Jeux Olympiques presque plus que
pour gagner un titre mondial et puis
c'est aussi de répétition pour le fait
de Drôme parce que c'est là que relu
aussi les Jeux Olympiques donc ils vont
être c'est vrai que c'est championnats
du monde doit être observé aussi par les
par les organisateurs des JO pour voir
comment ça se passe il y a pas
d'amicroche et voilà il faut croiser les
doigts pour que tout se passe bien parce
qu'on le rappelle les Yvelines vont
accueillir plusieurs épreuves il y a ce
vélo drone avec les épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste de paracyclisme sur piste les
épreuves aussi des crimes du pentathlon
moderne on pense forcément aussi à
d'autres sites comme le Golf National de
50 ans en Yvelines la colline
d'Élancourt il y aura aussi beaucoup
d'épreuves autour de Versailles je sais
que l'amoureux que vous êtes vous aussi
Patrice mais je sais qu'on l'attend
quand même tous avec impatience cet
événement du côté effectivement et puis
il y a on l'a appris ces dernières
semaines il y a le Marathon de Paris le
marathon qui va passer partir de Paris
qui va passer faire une boucle dans les
Yvelines donc effectivement les Yvelines
sont carrément une terre olympique pour
2024 d'ailleurs il y a un marathon pour
tous c'est ce que vous avez prévu de
prendre votre ticket il y a encore des
dossards à gagner hein
on va peut-être faire courir
Jean-Baptiste amonique qui est venu sur
votre plateau il a fait le semi-marathon
des sables pour pour l'association mais
c'est d'aller chirurgie cardiaque ils
sont très bien sortis avec le maire ici
puisqu'on est à Port-Marly Cédric
et voilà peut-être qu'on va les
entraîner pour qu'ils aillent Jo vous
allez vous entraîner Nicolas est-ce que
le défi est lancé ce que vous prenez le
pari vous savez bon sport de
prédilection c'est le rugby donc je vais
peut-être postuler pour le rugby à 7 il
y a une course de 10 km aussi avec 2000
24 dossard à 10 km c'est plus abordable
donc voilà ça sera l'une des idées de
sortie reste quelques places nous
disaient Jean-Michel richefort qui était
notre invité sur le plateau du 7 8
basique est l'un des vices présidents la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme donc
n'hésitez pas à aller sur le site
justement de la Fédération Française de
cycliste peut protéger pour peut-être
avoir votre ticket pour assister à ces
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste qui se déroule donc jusqu'à
dimanche et c'est au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines
en d'autres idées de sortie à présent
dans cette émission et nous allons
prendre la direction de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye avec une
exposition ces femmes au Musée
départemental Maurice Denis des
peintures zinédites des tableaux
restaurés des œuvres phares les
visiteurs peuvent contempler cette
exposition jusqu'au 2 juillet avec le
travail d'artiste féminine peu connu
mais également celui de grands noms de
la peinture comme Gauguin on regarde
tout de suite le reportage de Mathilde
de Franco
le musée départemental Maurice Denis
fait sa rentrée avec une nouvelle
exposition mettant les femmes à
l'honneur la grandeur richesse de cette
disposition c'est qu'on mélange à la
fois des artistes extrêmement connus
comme Denis et Gauguin mais également
des artistes femmes entièrement méconnus
qui dans leur vie ont été retenus en
tant que fille de en tant que femme de
et Coco aujourd'hui on remet à l'honneur
en tant qu'artiste peintre qui était
pourtant souvent leur activité
principale
intitulé femme avec un S elle se
décompose en 5 parties femmes modèles
mère artiste parfois décors et aimé
[Musique]
les amateurs d'art pourront ainsi
admirer les portraits des femmes de
Maurice Denis mais également le travail
de ses élèves ou de sa fille
du portrait de Alice 7 à part Théo
vannerg et on a cette touche
pointilliste absolument phénoménale dans
ce tableau les visiteurs pourront
découvrir cette exposition jusqu'au 2
juillet 2023 au total elle regroupe une
quarantaine d'oeuvres issues
essentiellement des collections du musée
certaines peintures sont d'ailleurs
présentées au public pour la première
fois
[Musique]
et puis toujours à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
une idée de sortie pour le week-end
prochain avec modération tout de même
c'est un salon des bières peut-être que
Nicolas est intéressé à côté de moi qui
se déroule samedi dimanche si ton
organisé par le Rotary Club de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye on écoute
l'interview express de Mélanie pocket
[Musique]
nous avons cherché à pouvoir soutenir
les filières régionales
Île-de-France donc des brasseurs aussi
des producteurs régionaux
on avait les précédents éditions a été
avant le le confinement et on sait que
c'est filières ont quand même été
impactés par le confinement et donc on a
souhaité justement pouvoir redynamiser
et aider cette filière
[Musique]
nous avons avoir une trentaine de stands
une quinzaine de stands donc de
brasseurs artisanaux nous allons avoir
deux ou trois stands de whisky cidre et
Rome et nous aurons aussi des stands de
produits régionaux donc on peut prêt
pour moitié qui seront des de la
charcuterie de la fumerie de poisson
d'épicerie fine de la biscuiterie
[Musique]
et tous les bénéfices de cette action de
ce salon vont être versés à
l'association à l'Institut womensf and
Sheeran qui est une association dont le
siège est à Saint-Germain-en-Laye fondé
en 2014 et cette association est
destinée à venir en aide aux femmes et
enfants victimes de violence
[Musique]
retour ici au Port-Marly les universités
des mairies des Yvelines et de l'ouest
parisien même plus généralement se
dérouler ici sur ce lieu TV 78 avait
d'ailleurs installé son plateau au coeur
de l'événement et sur le terrain vous
avez peut-être croisé des étudiants de
Sciences Po Saint-Germain-en-Laye
aspirant journaliste qui vivait
aujourd'hui leur première expérience de
terrain Nicolas un souvenir d'une
première expérience comme étudiant comme
journaliste professionnel c'est c'était
quoi moi je me suis premier reportage
d'un reportage en école de journalisme
au Palais Nikaïa déjà de la politique à
l'époque on était en plein dans les
primaires socialistes de 2011 et Martine
Aubry était venu au Palais Nikaia à Nice
pour ameting et c'était l'un des
premiers reportages politiques et vous
grégorez ben moi c'était aussi un
reportage politique alors on va changer
de bord politique moi c'était un meeting
de Nicolas Sarkozy c'était du côté de la
commune de Vélizy-Villacoublay et à
l'époque je travaillais dans une radio
locale et c'est vrai que bah on en garde
des souvenirs c'est impressionnant aussi
d'être sur le terrain première ces
grandes personnalité alors qu'on est
étudiant et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
étudiants de Sciences Po ont dû se
régaler alors vous avez vu qui par
exemple justement juste pour les
présenter Nicolas juste pour dire qu'on
a eu nous on a eu la chance la TV 78
d'abord 2 étudiantes qui nous ont prêté
main fortes sur cette journée elles ont
réalisé des interviews elles ont été sur
le terrain de nos parler justement de ce
qu'elles ont pu faire sur ces
universités des mairies on a Enza
benotchi et Solène alifa bonsoir à
toutes les deux premiers apparition télé
peut-être pour vous aujourd'hui
alors juste pour vous présenter alors on
va essayer de vous mettre le plus à
l'aise possible et juste préciser que
vous êtes étudiante en Master 1 du côté
de Sciences Po si on se pose
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et vous êtes
toutes les deux sur une prépa
journaliste c'est ça mais justement la
question déjà première question pourquoi
le parcours de journaliste pourquoi vous
dirigez vers cette carrière
professionnelle Solène je pense que
toutes les deux on se n'est pas
forcément aux journalistes au début on a
fait une classe préparatoire littéraire
ensemble parce que des sujets variés
nous intéressait et après ça s'est fait
un petit peu naturellement justement
cette idée de pouvoir toucher à tout
apprendre un peu tous les jours
rencontrer des gens et pouvoir informer
voilà et puis avec
l'actualité qui est très chaude
également en ce moment bah forcément on
a voilà on a pris on prend plaisir à
toujours creuser cette actualité
et c'est également ça que que demande le
métier de journaliste
sur le tard plutôt Nicolas c'est bon il
est présenté nos invités nos étudiants
vous pouvez poser votre question
justement on a parlé de nos expériences
nos premières expériences vous est-ce
que aujourd'hui il y a une personnalité
qui vous a marqué de la voix d'échanger
peut-être avec elle personnalité
politique
alors nous on a fait une interview en
live d'un gendarme sur le sur le stand
de la gendarmerie et au milieu de
l'interview est arrivé Gérard Larcher
donc ça a été aussi impressionnant de
devoir gérer le cadrage etc de voir
arriver cette personnalité qu'on avait
vu que sur les plateaux télés
impressionnant au-delà de ça ça nous a
aussi vraiment on a ça nous a montré que
voilà le journaliste devait être un
caméléon devrait devait vraiment devoir
s'adapter et être aussi très polyvalent
donc on a vraiment été confronté à ça et
ça a été ça a été un réel plaisir
interview d'un gendarme c'est l'occasion
de repréciser que c'est vrai c'est un
rendez-vous pour les élus mais c'est
aussi pour rencontrer justement tous
leurs partenaire des professionnels des
entreprises des institutions qui a été
présentes aujourd'hui sur ces pyramides
du Port-Marly pour ces universités des
mairies vous avez parlé de l'interview
d'un agenda vous avez croisé aussi
Gérard Larcher qu'est-ce que vous avez
pu faire d'autres aujourd'hui sur sur
cette journée alors pendant la première
partie de la matinée on a été pris en
charge par Michael qui nous a vraiment
formé
pour la pour la caméra donc il nous a
appris à au cadrage du cadrage et puis
la deuxième partie de la fin la deuxième
partie de la journée pendant
l'après-midi on a été beaucoup plus
autonome beaucoup plus libre Mélanie
nous a indiqué quelques directives et
puis après on a pu aller interviewer des
des élus des maires et c'était aussi un
plaisir c'est l'occasion de salut amical
et le midoro Mélanie poquet journaliste
de la rédaction de TV 78 qui ont été à
vos côtés première découverte du coup
avec le avec la caméra avec le cadrage
c'est c'est une découverte oui tout à
fait
découvre en fait justement en toutes ces
facettes du mais cette journaliste que
qu'il faut maîtriser
on découvre le matériel on apprend à
l'apprivoiser on apprend à poser des
questions etc donc c'était très
formateur très intéressant Nicolas moi
je sais que le souvenir de ce premier
reportage m'avait encore renforcé
l'envie de faire cette profession est-ce
que vous aujourd'hui finalement déjà un
bilan de cette journée et est-ce que ça
a renforcé l'envie de devenir
journaliste
oui je pense que vraiment c'est vraiment
intéressant et ça nous permet aussi de
découvrir voilà toutes ces facettes là
du métier et on se rend compte aussi que
c'est très fatigant de courir après les
interviews toute la journée de
d'apprendre plein de choses etc mais
oui c'est aussi très stimulant donc
adaptation c'est vrai que Elsa parlait
du côté caméléon on est capable de
parler de tous les de tous les sujets
oui quel souvenir vous allez en garder
vous êtes cette journée vraiment le fait
de devoir être très polyvalent même là
on est arrivé on nous a dit bon bah ce
soir vers 16h vous serez sur le plateau
bon bah on s'adapte enfin je veux dire
voilà et du coup c'est intéressant parce
que là on se retrouve de l'autre côté de
la caméra toute la journée on filmait là
maintenant on est filmé donc ouais
vraiment ce côté polyvalent et caméléon
c'est les deux mots que je retiens
d'autres événements à venir pour vous à
couvrir ce que vous savez déjà où est-ce
que vous allez vous rendre prochainement
alors je pense que on va nous demander
dans le cadre de la de la Préval
journaliste où on est de couvrir des
événements mais plus de façon
indépendante moins encadrées on va dire
par des journalistes comme ici qui était
vraiment le gros événement de l'année et
après avoir si on arrive à continuer
dans cette voie on sera amené à faire
avoir plus d'expérience on espère juste
oui on sait que vous Grégory votre rêve
c'est une interview avec John Luigi
Buffon le grand gardien de football
italien est-ce que vous vous avez un
rêve une personnalité que vous souhaitez
que vous souhaitez interviewer il révèle
ma vie secrète Nicolas dandry mais bon
oui est-ce que il y a peut-être un
aboutissement pour vous dans cette
carrière peut-être une personnalité un
événement peut-être un événement un
sujet que vous rêveriez traités moi je
pense que au-delà des interviews ce que
j'aimerais c'est pouvoir découvrir aussi
d'autres pays par le journaliste et
pouvoir couvrir un peu plus l'actualité
internationale
au-delà de une personne en particulier
aussi
la découverte à travers à travers le
journalisme Enza le mot de la finition
pour vous ce soir moi je voudrais
vraiment remercier je pense au nom de
nous deux on voudrait remercier l'équipe
TV 78 et puis Michael et Mélanie qui ont
vraiment les remercier pour leur
bienveillance et puis les conseils
précieux qui nous ont donné pendant
toute cette journée un grand merci à
vous merci à vous Enza merci Solène on
découvrira votre travail notamment
demain on diffusera un reportage sur ces
universités des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien on peut le découvrir d'ores et
déjà également sur les réseaux de
sociaux de TV 78 merci et bravo et bonne
suite dans votre dans vos études votre
carrière merci de journaliste avant de
vous quitter on va acheter un petit coup
d'œil à la météo de demain
et ce 13 octobre alors c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle sera nuageux dans les
Yvelines attention la pluie pourrait
même s'inviter dans la journée en début
d'après-midi avec quelques averses
annoncés côté température Panthéon 11
degrés le matin l'après-midi le
thermomètre grimpera à 17 degrés et
malheureusement dans les prochains jours
vous le voyez ce sera à pluvieux dans le
département à noter que ce jeudi 13
octobre nous fêterons les héros voilà
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 spécial
enregistré ici depuis les pyramides du
Port-Marly à l'occasion des universités
des mairies de l'Ouest parisien merci de
votre fidélité et belle soirée à tous
sur TV 78
[Musique]